[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so verließ
werdet heute gibt es eine ganz schnelle
torte ich mache nämlich ein tiramisu im
bug ring und dazu gibt es frische
früchte also dieses gefüllt mit
mascarpone joghurt creme also ein
bisschen leichter als die typischen
tiramisu und dann habe ich noch
brombeeren und himbeeren
ihr könnt natürlich früchte eurer wahl
verwenden und das möchte ich schon drauf
wie ich freu mich drauf
und vor allem kann man die torte einfach
morgen zwar kurz zubereiten also ich hab
jetzt nicht länger als eine halbe stunde
gebraucht dann im kühlschrank stellen
vier stunden kühlen und fertigt habe am
abend oder am nachmittag ein perfektes
bisher und ich zeige euch jetzt mal mit
welches habe ich arbeite für die torte
brauche ich etwa 200 gramm
löffelbiskuits einen kaffee oder zwei
espresso 250 gramm mascarpone 250 gramm
sahne 500 gramm naturjoghurt in zehn
prozent fett stufe ich brauche etwas
seiner partei 100 gramm puderzucker eine
unbehandelte zitrone etwas vanille
extrakt und jeweils 100 gramm himbeeren
und brombeeren oder auch früchte eurer
wahl
ich bereite jetzt zuerst mal die creme
so und dafür kommen jetzt die zutaten in
die schüssel also einfach den mascarpone
ein wenig es gerne etwas leichter machen
möchtet dann könnt ihr die mascarpone
auch ersetzen durch quark zum beispiel
die mascarpone macht eben auch richtig
schön cremig und der joghurt passt dann
eben auch hervorragend dazu und macht
sowieso schon ein bisschen leichter im
geschmack hier dann macht die sache rein
erst einmal nur die hälfte dann kann ich
das ganze ganz kurz verhör damit das
gefühl dass ich mit sahne verbindet
jetzt kommen die übrige sahne das so und
ich gebe auch gleich den joghurt dazu
[Musik]
dann noch der puderzucker zitronenschale
und zitronensaft und da solltet ihr eine
unbehandelte zu tode nehmen
[Musik]
für den geschmack noch etwas vanille
extrakt und dann kann ich jetzt die
creme rühren und während im winter
sonderfahrt einfügen und die creme steif
schlagen
[Musik]
jetzt kann die torte schon geschichtet
werden darf er nehme ich jetzt den
kaffee geht dann einfach in seinen
teller und wer möchte kann dem café und
auch der creme zum beispiel noch ein
bisschen himbeergeist zufügen jetzt
nimmt ihr die löffel biscuit punkt sie
hier einen und dadurch werden sie auch
ein bisschen weich und somit kann ich
auch eine runde form damit befüllen
ich nehme jetzt hier einfach einen
tortenring gehen habe ich bereits auf
eine tortenplatte gesetzt und kann jetzt
die komplette form damit auslegen
[Musik]
die löffel bis jetzt habe ich wirklich
ganz ganz dicht an den boden gedrückt
und teilweise einfach auch zerbrochen
und in die lücken eingefüllt jetzt kommt
die sahne creme an die reihe davon gehe
ich jetzt die hälfte hier ein
[Musik]
darüber kommen jetzt die bären der bombe
chris lee barry braunbär teddy bear
und darüber kommt jetzt die restliche
creme und dann kann ich die torte
abdecken und für mindestens 4 stunden in
den kühlschrank stellen
und das war es dann schon
[Musik]
kurator das problem ist ja auch richtig
schön schnittfest also ich hab jetzt
ehrlich muss er sagen ich wünsche mir
jetzt das sind zu süß ist dann probieren
einfach kriegen mit joghurt mascarpone
samen zitronenschale sei natürlich
richtig lehrer genau ein - so
vorgestellt selbst ja du hast mich nicht
überrascht muss ich ehrlich sagen jetzt
noch keine himbeeren bar und im garten
aber mit in himbergen proben aus dem
garten schmeckt natürlich noch besser
was er da freuen wir uns drauf und
wahnsinn gern und ich finde ja auch echt
schön auch mal pro kind der 23 ist ja
wenn man mal drin freie eingeladen ist
heute kurz zusammen stellen im
kühlschrank und ab geht die post
und wenn das nicht als tote machen will
kann man natürlich auch in eine
auflaufform machen wenn man doch nicht
so viel zeit hat dann kann man es
nämlich heraus dass ich den boden dafür
biscuit getränk im café cool oder wow
ich liebe halb cafés gibt es ja falls
ihr dieses rezept auch gerne nachmachen
möchte jetzt schaut auf meinem blog
vorbei ist er lief - blog.de und da
steht alles noch mal ganz genau ich
freue mich schon auf eure fotos von
eurer tiramisu torte und ich denke wir
müssen unbedingt mal klassisch das
tiramisu machen hast es geschafft
innerhalb einer minute eine torte zu
essen
wir müssten mal eine challenge machen
wie lange braucht morath für eine große
torte hat sech net gesungen es langsam
genieße ich hab ich meine espresso dazu
wie sie mit ihren ponys unter druck
gesetzt warum weiß nicht so recht ob für
die ok als er falls ja auch so etwas
leckeres essen wollt dann schaut auf
meinem blog vorbei ich wünsche euch viel
spaß danach braucht man wahrscheinlich
falsch beim nachmachen und bis zum
nächsten mal
ich melde dich bald beim meine
schnellste es hatte wendet an
[Musik]